the beer brand Dos Equis has announced
they found their new most interesting
man in the world this is a true story
check it out there he is they've chosen
a French actor named Augustine Legrand
hey Conan yes sir
are you sure they aren't too still
nothing for in interesting man no
they're right sir I just made it very
clear they're not looking for a new
motor Cement they just announced that it
is final
too bad I am the most interesting man in
the world really sir tell us why is that
I once ate three pancakes for breakfast
No
[Applause]
now sir that's not that interesting you
want interesting I just found this
potato that look just like with Jodie
crew service
his name is George Clooney and that
potato does not look like him you're
wrong I solve this Rubik's Cube just by
listening to it
sir that cube isn't even solved now look
sir like I said dose akise has already
chosen their man that's it
fine let's get our over here is that a
helicopter noises two helicopters stay
thirsty my friend
[Applause]
[Applause]
wait a minute
he orders two helicopters and then walks
away
safety first that's a berry
you